Let's write 113.9% as a decimal.
So percent, this
symbol right over here,
literally means per hundred.
So this is the same
thing as 113.9 per 100,
which is the same thing
as 113.9 divided by 100.
So essentially, if we want
to write this as a decimal,
we just take a 113.9,
and we divide it by 100.
And to do that,
113.9 divided by 100.
If you divide by 10, you move
the decimal once to the left.
If you divide by 100, you're
moving the decimal twice
to the left.
If we're doing it by 1,000, we
would go to the left once more.
10,000, each time
you divide by 10,
you'd go one step to the left,
which hopefully makes sense.
If we were to multiply by 10,
we would be moving the decimal
over to the right, and
there are other videos
that go into far more depth
on the intuition behind that.
But anyway, we're
dividing 113.9 by 100,
so move the decimal
two spaces to the left.
So the decimal will
end up right over here.
So this will be equal to 1.139.
And we are done.